foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
Innovative tools for efficient crispr
cast genome engineering this webinar is
part of the fifth annual crispr virtual
event and I'm Susie Valdez of lab roots
and I will be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
IDT for more information about IDT go to
idtdna.com now let's get started before
we begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the left of your screen
that you can also participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click submit now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation just click on that help
desk button located at the top of your
screen with the navigation bar or from
the lobby and finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on that continuing education credits
link located in the abstract tab from
the menu on the left and use the screen
and follow the process to obtain those
credits I now present today's speaker Dr
Gavin kurgan a bioinformatics
application manager at integrated DNA
Technologies for a complete biography of
our speakers please visit the presenter
tab from the menu on the left of your
screen Dr kurgan welcome you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction I just
want to start off and say thank you to
labyrinths for putting on the fifth
annual crispr 2022 event uh I'm really
excited to speak with everyone today and
share some of the work that we've been
doing at IET
um so briefly my name is Gavin kurgan
I'm a bioinformatics applications
manager here at IDT and today I kind of
put together a pretty broad topic crispr
talk to talk and discuss a lot of the
Innovative work we've been doing at IDT
and how that impacts a number of
different crispr cast workflows
so as a quick review the main enzymes in
the genome editing toolkit that we
provide and that are often used to edit
mammalian cells are usually cas9 and
cast 12a
these two enzymes have distinct
mechanisms structural requirements and
different levels of specificity but
using either enzyme a double strand
break is generated at a targeted
location in the genome which the cell
now needs to repair this is done using
the cells endogenous DNA repair Pathways
and the specific preferential outcomes
here can really vary from cell type to
cell type but generally speaking there's
two main mechanisms that are leveraged
by researchers to generate mutations in
the resulting cell population
when no donor DNA template is provided
the cell predominantly undergoes
non-homologous end joining which can
generate variable insertions deletions
and substitutions adjacent and
overlapping with the site of the double
strand rate alternatively If a DNA donor
template is provided with homology arms
targeting the regions adjacent to the
double strand break shown here in blue
specific mutations can be incorporated
into the resulting population of cells
using the homology directed repair
pathway
however a key finding of crispr genome
editing like many other oligar
Therapeutics is that the targeting of
these enzymes is imperfect it may induce
off-target unintended double strain
breaks at similar genomic loci
here you can see the output of an
empirical off-target nomination tool
guide seek for a guide targeting the
emx1g the number of reads of this
workflow generally correspond to the
prevalence of these off-target editing
events and here you can see that the On
Target site with the most reads at the
top and some of the identified
off-target loci and the respective
mismatches to the targeting sequence
shown below this is just one method of
many for nominating off-target sites but
the techie takeaway here is the off
Target double strand breaks occur and
identifying and quantifying their impact
is important
and so all of this is pretty much a
primer like I said this is going to be a
pretty broad uh presentation and kind of
topic but my goal here is to try and
help connect all these different pieces
of the genome editing toolkit and how
those tools are currently being
innovated on here at IDT
here you can see a broad range of our
product portfolio starting with design
tools to help create oligos and perform
and interrogate genome editing the
reagents and proteins that need to be
coupled with these oligos to make them
functional the broad swath of your
different enhancers and oligo types for
enhancing targeted DNA repair and then
finally the tools provided to actually
detect the genome editing experiments
and we'll walk through each of these
throughout the presentation
so first we'll cover considerations and
design of both guides and donor oligos
for HDR and the IDT tools that exist to
help perform these tasks
so guide RNA design is one of the most
important first elements of experimental
design this requires you to ask what
region of the genome you are targeting
what kind of Pam or enzyme requirements
you have if you're going to be
leveraging highly specialized guide rnas
for introducing edits and what kind of
metrics should be optimized in guide
selection from here people can leverage
existing IDT tools to design guides for
both standard and custom app locations
design large arrayed functional targeted
libraries or design guides with the
intention of introducing and edit
through the repair Pathways like
homology directed repair
first we'll actually just discuss the
basics of how tools throughout the IDT
portal can actually be used to perform
both standard and custom guide RNA
design and synthesis though
for cas9 guide rnas with an ngg Pam we
have a full guide RNA design tool that
supports most popular genomes and
generates both on and off Target scores
to help prioritize which guides are best
for a desired region can then be
relatively easily funneled into a lot of
our standard you know two-part or sgrna
products and can be ordered in bulk
however many people may use custom
nucleases or guide rnas that are highly
specialized like Peg rnas for Prime
editing for these applications we have a
custom guide RNA ordering tool that can
accept lengths from 130 to 150
nucleotides and many of our standard
modification patterns all in a single
submission or in bulk formats
this includes you know basically
designing for guides like cast 12a cast
13 like I said Peg rnas and more uh all
you really need to do is have means to
design the sequence which can be done
through several specialized open source
tools
um and it should be noted we can design
and we can synthesize guide rnas longer
than our standard 150 nucleotides
however these are evaluated kind of on a
custom ordering process to make sure
that the synthesized product can
actually be held to IDT quality stand
when someone wants to generate a large
functional screen of the genome though
this doesn't often fit easily into the
standard ordering processes especially
because it requires special design
considerations and ordering mechanisms
for that we have a special service for
accepting guide RNA Library design
currently we support design of synthetic
array crispr libraries for those new to
the subject these are typically
introduced into experimental paradigms
where the goal is to screen a large
number of genes for phenotypic outcomes
and high throughput
for example you may have a plate of
cells stable expressing cas9 or that are
prepared to be co-transfected with an
rmp along with this array guide RNA
Library degree
these libraries are designed to
typically have multiple guides per
transfection that are all targeting the
same gene in one well from there there
is a high level of functional knockout
typically observed which makes this
plate of edited cells ideal for
screening to identify Gene candidates of
Interest which I'm indicating is you
know Positive Hits here with yellow
stars
one thing that we have worked a lot on
recently is optimizing how these are
done so that we can provide an optimized
design and synthesis service for
performing guide RNA Library screens for
starters we looked into just how many
guide rnas are actually needed in a well
to get really robust editing across 96
different genomic targets using our
guides and design algorithm
this led to our recommendation to try
and design three guidance rnas purging a
target for robust editing but also
enabling two which still allows very
high levels of editing as seen on the
left
then we perform designs for this type of
experiment uh to do this we created an
automated tool to look up Exxon usage
patterns and annotated and canonical
transcripts and look to Target exons
which will disrupt the most common
transcripts as early as possible in the
shared targetable exons
from here we look to place highly
functional guides within a region
interrogatable by amplicon sequencing to
enable Downstream genotyping with
Illumina sequencing
and all of this can kind of be seen in
that graphic in the middle we've
included a number of other optimizations
as well where our design guides are
actually selected to attempt to optimize
frameshift frequency by targeting
certain genomic contexts and sequence
repair features that we're aware of that
here you can see that on the right where
the currently utilized strategy
highlighted it in green on the left
outperforms designs were only on off
Target information is used which is
highlighted in Orange to prioritize
guide RNA selections as is done in many
other algorithms
however our designs are handled on a
custom process and can accommodate
customer requested changes as required
and can be reached using the link at the
bottom of the slide
lastly when guides are being designed to
ultimately introduce targeted changes
through homology directed repair this
requires specific optimizations that we
recommend go through our HDR design tool
some of the reasons why it is so
important to consider guide RNA designed
simultaneously with HDR donor design can
be seen with these two graphics
for one we know that HDR efficacy is
greatly affected by the relative
location of the guide RNA cut site to
the intended introduce changes here as
you can see HDR indicated on the left
graph's left axis and the distance to
the cut site to an introduced Eco R1
insertion via a donor on the x-axis
as distance from the cut site increases
HDR efficacy drops especially without
the introduction of what we call tract
mutations which are non-coding mutations
that are introduced along the way to an
intended change to attempt to favor
complete introduction of donor mutations
instead of partial introduction secondly
we can see on the right when we consider
targeted mutations that are not near a
cut site The Strand used to introduce
donor guided mutations is particularly
important with non-target strand donors
being more effective introducing
mutations five Prime of the cas9 cut
site whereas Target strand donors are
more effective in introducing mutations
three prime of the cut site as distance
increase if we increase introduce these
track mutations that I mentioned earlier
on the correct strand high levels of HDR
can still be maintained as indicated by
the track annotation on the x-axis on
the graph on the right with the y-axis
indicating the perfect the perfect HDR
frequency relative to an insertion right
at the kind of site following this work
we realized it would be good to have a
design tool that considered guide
information in the context of what
donors could introduce a desire mutation
this led to the creation of our altar
HDR design tool
the altar HDR design tool is an
interactive web-based tool reachable at
the link at the bottom right that makes
it a lot easier to consider the need to
co-optimize HDR donors along with their
respective guides and Order both it
allows you to come with a number of
different inputs types to help specify
the mutation you're interested in that
you would like to create and adjust
experimental parameters like homology
arm size the use of Silent mutations and
more many of these parameters come with
intelligently defined defaults as seen
in one of our recent Publications
but you can always come with your
preferred guide RNA or search for the
best guiding RNA given your mutation of
Interest I think it's always pretty hard
to explain interactive tools and
slideshows but I would just highly
recommend checking it out for your next
experiment it also allows you to preview
your translation before and after the
theoretical edit to make sure you're
really making the functional change that
you hope to
next I'll switch to discussing the
different enzymes and formulations you
can choose in performing crispr cast
genome engineering
IDT offers several different enzymes for
genome engineering with quite a few IDP
exclusive mutants which are highlighted
here in Orange
we offer both cas9 and cast 12a enzymes
which allow for editing based on the
presence of ngg or tttv Pam sequences
near your desired editing location for
cas9 nucleuses we offer both wild type
and HiFi cas9 that was developed using
bacterial mutagenesis the original as
and lb enzymes for cas12a also have
issues with low on Target and editing so
we engineered higher activities of both
of these different enzymes finally we
have fluorescently labeled cas9 options
like cas9 gfp and RFP that allow for
visualization of delivery although I
won't talk uh in great detail about
those today
wild type enzymes can have significant
off-target editing depending on what
guide and delivery method is used here
we can see just how important
quantifying off-target editing effects
is for an avs1 targeting guide and 28
nominated off Target low side that we
evaluated in-house under variable
experimental conditions here you can see
the percent editing Quantified by NGS on
the y-axis with each on or off Target on
the x-axis
using a cell line with continuous
expression of wild-tech cas9 complex we
observe a large amount of editing at the
On Target and also highly prevalent
editing at these 28 off-target loci
by simply switching to ribonuclear
effect nuclear protein nucleus action we
can see that editing at these off-target
both sides greatly decreased this really
emphasizes the importance of optimizing
the delivery mechanism of your crispr
cast complex for highly specific editing
furthermore by switching to a highly
specific crispr cast enzyme variant like
our altar HiFi cas9 these off-target
effects can be further reduced while
maintaining efficient editing at the On
Target site we recently published
results on this cas9 mutant in 2018 with
the publication title listed below
this engineered variant was recently
benched marked independently in the
creation of the 2020 TT ISS method for
profiling cas9 endonucleases here
relative activity of different nucleases
was tested with respect to activity as
measured on the y-axis and specificity
as measured on the x-axis relative to
wild-type cas9 it can be seen here that
our HiFi cas9 is one of the most
specific engineered cast-9 variants
tested that manages to still maintain
comparable activity to wild-type cas9
which is seen in the top left corner
a popular alternative to the cas9 system
is cast 12a otherwise known as cpf1 this
system uses a short single guide RNA and
is natively highly specific in contrast
to cast 9 which recognizes GC Rich ngt
pams the Precast 12a protein recognizes
tttb pans it also is a smaller protein
in size as compared to cas9
as mentioned earlier wild type as cast
12a is not as efficient at editing the
Genome of human cells as other enzymes
like SP cas9 so we undertook an effort
to perform scanning site saturation
munagenesis coupled the Deep sequencing
to identify variants that increase
genome editing activity here on the left
you can see the result of this screening
from around 300 nucleotides to 1300
nucleotides but in the as cast 12a
sequence before and after selection of
beneficial variants the Peaks here
indicate enrichment of certain mutations
this allowed us to identify the
m537r and f-870l mutations that make up
our vastly improved as cas12a Ultra
enzyme
the graphic in the middle shows how the
ultra mutation mutant greatly improves
editing as measured on the y-axis at 96
different sites in hect293 cells as
compared to the wild type as cost-12a
nucleus additionally performance of this
variant has comparable editing efficacy
as compared to SP cas9
recent work that we collaborated with
editos medicine on use this engineered
nucleus and the editing of T cells and
hspcs and saw that the benefits observed
in hecti93 cells are transferable to
more relevant cell types for genomic
medicine workflows
while both Hi-Fi cas9 and as cast 12a
Ultra are excellent genome editing tools
other application demand additional
tools
specifically in the field of Agriculture
most editing is done in plants that grow
and reproduce at lower temperatures
lbcast 12a is an orthologic as cast 12a
that is known to function better in
Plants however similar to Wild type A is
cast 12a it also suffers from poor On
Target potency and many of the mutations
published for as cast 12a including our
own are not directly transferable to the
lbcast 12a
to this end we undertook another effort
to perform scanning site saturation
mutagenesis of all positions in the
lbcast 12a protein the best mutants from
this Library were stacked and tested
using four different guides in human
cell lines initially as single mutation
variants from here we found 16 mutants
that were positive hits for increased
activity and proceeded to combine the
best mutations is double triple and
quadruple mutants the relative activity
of these mutants compared to the wild
type lbcast 12a are shown here on the
y-axis and the most universally improved
stack mutant was called lbcast 12a Ultra
and is shown in this graphic with the
red asterisk in the triple mutant
category
similar to our previous effort with the
ascast 12a pro team the lbcast 12a ultra
protein intended for use in agricultural
editing demonstrates improved editing
efficiencies relative to the wild type
protein we demonstrated that here with
collaborators from the University of
Maryland with six ttb Pam targets and
plant protoplasts at low temperatures of
both 25 degrees Celsius and 32 degrees
Celsius
gear the lbcast 12a ultra protein shows
improved efficiency at all conditions
compared to the wild type protein
now that we've talked about the guide
rnas and proteins used to edit the
genome we can discuss some of the
different reagents and oligos used to
drive editing towards intended genomic
changes
as mentioned prior after a double strand
break the cell needs to repair DNA
ideally for intended genomic changes we
want the cell to utilize the homology
directed repair Pathway to repair the
brake using an exogenously provided
donor DNA however a number of different
factors affect the efficacy of repair
through HDR including how the donor
oligo is designed the format in which it
is provided and even the cell cycle and
transcriptional profile of the edited
cells here we'll discuss the different
options and optimizations that can be
leveraged for this step
After cast 9 or your crispr enzyme of
choice generates a double strand break
ideally your donor will result in a nice
clean repair through HDR when using a
single strand DNA template as shown here
this is the primary outcome shown here
on the left however there are additional
misincorporation outcomes through
negj-based mechanisms that we'll address
more in just a moment
when it comes to generating short
insertions or snps IDT offers our alt R
HDR donor oligo product these are
modified oligos that are manufactured
using our high quality Ultra chemistry
they're low-cost options and are great
honestly generally for
generating these types of smaller edits
when it comes to large insertions we
have historically offered a long single
strand DNA template called megamers
however these long single strand dnas
can be challenging to make which leads
to higher costs lower turnaround time
and greater limitations on the types of
sequence complexities that can be
accepted to address some of these
limitations for our customers we began
to consider options for double strand
DNA templates
unmodified linear double-strand DNA such
as G blocks high five Gene fragments
work well for HDR but do have one major
drawback
the blunt ends of the donor can also be
recognized by the nhej repair Machinery
leaning to the possibility of homology
independent or blunt integration of the
donor shown here on the right side of
the graphic at the On Target double
strand break this leads to the
duplication of one or more homology
errors for long templates this is
generally a low frequency event that can
be screened down however this can also
occur at an endogenous double strand
brakes or at cast 9 off Target double
strand brake sites unless you are
looking for them they could have
unwanted effects Downstream so we asked
the question can modifications to the
ends of the double strand DNA mitigate
the risk of this unwanted event
so we conducted an experiment with short
double strand dnas with variable oligom
modifications once we had identified top
modifications from an initial screen we
then set out to further confirm them in
additional cell lines and at additional
sites
see the results here of testing variable
modifications in three different cell
lines at five different genomic loci the
y-axis here shows the average full
change of HDR blunt integration in the
HDR blunt ratio compared to an
unmodified double-strand DNA template
for each modification on the x-axis
from this we found that our top
modification pattern labeled as the alt
R mod here improve the ratio of HDR to
blunt insertions at the On Target site
four-fold
this product is now available as our
altar HDR donor block product which can
go up to 3 KB it offers faster cheaper
and more flexible options a more
flexible option to our long single
strand DNA product
Additionally the modifications we've
Incorporated promote HDR while reducing
unwanted blunt integration shown here
with the arrows
however sometimes it is still desirable
to further Drive outcomes to HDR with
additional approaches an additive
approach to promoting HDR is the use of
either small molecules or peptides to
modulate the transcriptional and
functional activity of DNA repair
pathways
this can dramatically improve HDR rates
and additionally drive down unwanted
repair outcomes
out are currently available product is
the altar HDR enhancer V2 but I'll also
give a sneak peek of one of our upcoming
peptide products for improving HDR in
this section
to look for small molecules that improve
homology directed repair outcomes We
performed a screen a screen of a number
of different small molecules including
many of those that had been previously
published the y-axis in this graphic
indicates the percent perfect HDR while
the x-axis is indicating all the
different small molecule treatments
tested this led to the initial
identification of our HDR enhancer B1
which is shown here in light green since
then though we've continued screening
and identified more compounds and let to
which lets the identification of our HDR
enhancer V2 shown here in dark green
which provides significant Improvement
for HDR rates even above the B1 enhancer
in addition to the best Improvement in
HDR efficiency the V2 enhancer is also
delivered at a lower concentration which
allows for better cell viability as well
once we identified our oligom
modifications and ideal small molecules
for HDR we then went to look at how it
behaved with more difficult large
knock-ons relative to Alternative
templates
here in this graphic we're comparing
different repair templates when
generating gfp tags at three different
genomic low assignments without addition
any additional treatment we can see here
on the y-axis that long single strand
DNA gives around five percent HDR as a
baseline unmodified double stranded DNA
gets up to about nine percent and altar
modified double strand DNA boosts up to
15 HDR
we then use long-range sequencing to dig
further into the editing and can see
that the long single strand templates
actually results in a lot of partial
Integrations that are not observed as
frequently with double strand DNA
templates shown there on the right with
the igb plots
we then perform the same experiment in
the presence of HDR enhancer V2 and
we're pleased to see that the treatment
was very beneficial for the long double
strand DNA templates as well V2 enhancer
brings single strand DNA donors up to
about 10 to 20 percent versus up to 50
to 70 percent with the altar HDR donor
blocks
as I said earlier we also have a peptide
based and HDR enhancer coming soon there
are a number of different ways to try
and Target DNA repair but one is to
potentially enable end resection to
occur more freely it's been published
that the introduction of i-53 improves
HDR punitively by sequestering
sequestering 53 bp1 which is an
inhibitor event resection
we tested i-53 ourselves and while it
worked when delivered as plasmid the
results were relatively inconsistent and
different genomic loci when delivered as
protein alongside cas9 rnp you can see
those results here for one site where
increasing concentrations of i-53
protein are needed to see any sort of
significant effect for HDL represented
here on the y-axis thus we set out to
engineer a ubiquitinvariant with higher
affinity for 53 bp1 that would work
better when delivered as a protein
from another site saturation mutagenesis
effort we identified a number of single
amino acid changes that improved the
Affinity of i-53 for 53 dp1 shown here
on the right as a fold increase in
Infinity versus the wild type protein a
number of different mutants were
generated but two mutants with stack
mutations named ubva and ubb have vastly
improved affinity
when testing these mutants as functional
proteins the Improvement to HDR is
increased above what we originally
showed with wild type i53 in red but
also was efficacious at significantly
decreased concentrations of the actual
peptide itself
we then wanted to testify
ubiquitinvariants could be used as part
of a cocktail with other HDR enhancers
like our E2 enhancer
shown here is data looking at HDR rates
using ubva altar HDR enhancer V2 or both
in combination with different types of
donors including short single strand DNA
donors aav and long double strand DNA
donor
donor we find that while the test the
benefit of ubva compared to B2 depends
on donor type we see an additional boost
in HDR when they are used together with
the lack of observed toxicity promotion
of HDR by facilitating end resection and
compatibility with other HDR enhancers
we think that the ubiquitinvariance
targeting c53bp1 will be a valuable tool
to facilitate HDR
lastly once transfection has been
performed and cells edited there is a
need to quantify what the resulting
effects were we've shown a lot of data
that has relied on that but in this
section we'll talk a little bit more
about how the tools we've created enable
non-bioinformaticians to analyze NGS
data for these purposes
when we talk about selecting optimal
guide rnas and quantifying there effects
this usually begins by selecting the
best guides based on in-silico
predictions of on and off target editing
efficacies and verifying the guides
performance using a quick on target
editing activity app so this is then
used to select the most efficient guides
which then can have off-target effects
nominated using an empirical method like
guide secret change Secret
from here editing can be Quantified at
on and off Target sites simultaneously
using a multiplexed PCR which is
possible using the ramseek system that
I'll discuss shortly
however when we talk about quantifying
editing and on off Target low side there
are several methods that currently exist
with variable levels of features as
depicted in this graphic
one fast and cheap method is to perform
a heteroduplex assay such as a mismatch
using a mismatch endonuclease such as
the t71 or surveyor systems this method
is fast and can be performed at high
throughput but is unreliable when it
comes to quantification and provides no
information on the allylic distribution
of the evidence cells here we can see
the results from previously published
work where a known concentration of
edited DNA was used to evaluate the
accuracy of these happens we can see
here that t71 and surveyor systems
quantification of editing efficiency is
very approximate and only achieves a
rough quantification of this target when
30 to 50 percent of the DNA is at a
additionally t-71 and surveys systems
can only quantify editing at one Locus
at a time however this is also highly
dependent on the allylic diversity of
the population of edited cells
representing yet another caveat that can
lead to inaccurate quantification using
this method
danger traces can also be used to
approximate editing efficiency in the
allylic distribution of a site using
tools such as titerites here we can see
a graphic we adapted from Shapiro at all
that Quantified the difference in
editing efficiencies and NGS represented
on the x-axis or Sanger methods on the
y-axis for a number of sites although we
can see here that Sanger deconvolution
methods generally correlate well with
NGS results they consistently
underrepresent the editing efficiency of
a population of cells Additionally the
resolution on allylic diversity has
previously been reported to be low for
saying your assays and we can see that
as the editing efficiency drops below 10
indels these assays become erratic and
unreliable
this is why we recommend that next
Generation sequencing we use to quantify
the effects of on and off target editing
from crispr here we can see data derived
from our recent publication where we
evaluated the concentration of a
titrated double-strand DNA mixture with
a known concentration of indels in
comparison to what is Quantified using
NGS
the values here correlate well with
expectation done to 0.1 percent of
observed Windows which is around the
level of sequencing noise for this
sample NGS has high resolution of
allylic variant distribution in the
population and can be used to
simultaneously quantify on and off
target editing effects using the
multiplex PCR action like I said earlier
one caveat here however is that NGS
analysis really dependent on
bioinformatics software which which
requires accuracy and a lot of testing
really additionally sometimes even just
having access to bioinformatics
expertise is a significant barrier and
this is a major issue that I'll show you
how we solve with the Ramsey crispr
analysis system
so the Ramsey crispr analysis system is
a new end-to-end workflow we've
developed to help researchers quantify
the effects of on and off target editing
using NGS this includes developing RH
primers for Multiplex PCR using our
ramseek design tool preparing the
amplicon libraries using the
corresponding Master mix and analyzing
the sequencing data produced from an
aluminum I seek in an easy to use web
platform you can find more information
on any of these compounds the link below
components I should say however this
workflow allows researchers to Simply
come with a list of off-target locations
and convert this into high quality NGS
results without bioinformatics expertise
the Ramsey Christmases at mastermix
comes with credits to do NGS analysis
after sequencing
and the software for doing this analysis
is specifically designed to be user
friendly and not rely on local
computational resources for the sake of
time though I'm just going to focus here
on the capabilities of the NGS analysis
software that we call the Ramsey crispr
analysis tool instead of the whole
portfolio foreign
JS analysis software and don't other
open source software's already exist for
this and the short answer here is yes
but based on our own findings and
surveyed feedback it doesn't really
satisfy all end user needs these tools
currently consist of software like
crispresso crispresso 2 amplicon but we
found a number of customers struggling
with these tools the tools can neither
be difficult to use for those without
bioinformatics expertise or the accuracy
of the actual software has not been
fully characterized and validated and a
lot of these interfaces that exist
throughout all these softwares don't
really support High throughput
functionality and to have throughput
workflows for this we created a reason
we created our own tool by performing
several cas9 and cast 12a editing
experiments and character as in the
resulting in Dell profiles of these
experiments we use this to create a
biologically informed thoroughly
verified software package for crispr
genome editing with an easy to use web
interface here you can see how our tool
in green
outperforms other tools and annotating
editing efficiency in an internally
created in silico benchmarking data set
with a known amount of indels
represented as a black line in the
graphic
from a high level the analysis workflow
is as follows you first upload files
using either a drag and drop interface
or by picking the folder on your
Hardware that can be used to stream the
files into the interface
next you select your uploaded samples
and provide guide and amplicon
information to start an analysis run
lastly you can interpret the results of
individual or aggregated experiments
directly in the interface to quantify
important metrics like editing HDR
repair frequency friendship frequency
the population of alleles and more
finally we wanted to see how sensitive
the Ramsey crispr analysis system may be
for quantifying low levels of off-target
editing we thus created a truth set with
variable levels of endo spiked into 20
unedited genomic loci with background
Intel frequencies in our expected range
between 0.0 to 0.4 percent in Bells this
enabled us to create a set of paired
treatment and control sets that could be
categorized as true positives when a
control sample is compared to a
treatment sample or a true negative when
a control sample was compared to another
control
to provide a binary call if the sample
was edited or not We performed a
fisher's exact test on the paired
samples comparing the read count of wild
type and indel-containing Reeds for the
assigned treatment versus control this
allowed us to generate a p-value which
we then used as a threshold to qualify
anything with less than 0.05 as a truly
edited site
here you can see with that with about 47
to 56 pairs per indo-dilution level we
are able to correctly characterize 95
percent of true positives down to 0.5
percent indels in this data set which
correctly characterize while correctly
characterizing true negatives
approximately 95 percent of the time a
key requirement of this was performed
with at least you know that this was
performed with at least 5000 reads per
Target paired treatment controls and
background indulth levels less than 0.4
percent
and that really concludes a lot of the
newest Innovations and tools from IDT
that I wanted to share with everyone
here lastly if you want if you want more
general information about ramseek and
its applications please feel free to
follow this link
and with that I'd just like to say
thanks for tuning in to this webinar and
I'll take any questions the audience may
have
I want to thank you Dr kurgan for your
time today and for your important
research and before we go I want to
thank our audience for joining us as
well today I'd also like to thank our
sponsor IDT for sponsoring today's
webinar questions submitted today and
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration and this webcast can be
viewed on demand for two years until
November 2nd 2024. lab rates will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time take care everyone bye-bye